[Music]
have you ever looked at a cartoon
character and wondered what's going to
happen to them years down the line we
have it's always good to have a think
about how your favorite characters are
going to end up how have they matured
what have they done and also what do
they look like be sure to stay watching
until the end to see how we think a
modern-day Disney Princess will turn out
if this is your first time visiting the
things make sure you subscribe and give
this video a like today we're gonna take
a look at ten kids cartoon characters
reimagined as adults boo from monsters
Inc one of our favorite Pixar films is
the hilarious monsters Inc the tales of
Sully Mike and boo made us laugh when we
were youngsters and they make us laugh
now and it's not just us because it's
one of the most financially successful
animated films ever we really like boo
she's the little girl who won't be
frightened no matter how hard Sully and
Mike tried to scare her this got us
thinking about what boo would look like
when she grew up here's what we think
she looks like as you can see she's
still got her hair in bunches and she's
still got those trademark big brown eyes
we reckon that she will have grown up to
be a big strong and confident sort of
woman after all
if Mike and Sulley weren't able to scare
her we don't think there's pretty much
anything that could have here's an
interesting thing about boo it turns out
her real name is Mary when it was time
to write the book based on the film the
author named her after her voice actress
Mary Gibbs
and here's another crazy theory she's
actually the same person as violet from
The Incredibles some people look to
their similar appearances and the fact
that they're more powerful when they're
happy but as much as we'd like to
believe that we think they're totally
different people hey guys we are so
excited to announce we are producing our
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best DIYs fashion tips
makeup acts and so much more we are sure
you're going to love it
let us know what you think in the
comment section we love to hear from you
Agnes from the despicable Me movies
perhaps one of the most unlikely success
stories to have come out of the world of
cinema in the 21st century is the
despicable me franchise just think about
it for a moment the studio behind it
illumination entertainment had never
even made a movie before the 2010 film
hit cinemas but the tales of GRU his
adopted daughters Margo Edith and Agnes
not to mention the minions have wormed
their way into the hearts of moviegoers
across the globe we are big fans of all
the characters but today we're gonna
talk about the youngest of the three
sisters who were adopted by GRU and Lucy
at the end of the first film that's
right it's Agnes she's the little girl
who was the only one of the three who
was totally excited about becoming
Groove adopted daughter she's the one
who is absolutely obsessed with unicorns
and feels like she's going to die of
happiness and excitement when she wins a
fluffy toy when she's older we think
that she's going to be like this she'll
still wear something not unlike the
clothes she wore when she was at miss
Hattie's alongside Margot and Edith a
yellow top with denim trousers and we
really really hope that she's going to
keep her love of unicorns and tiled the
dog of course
Dora the Explorer millions of people
across the globe spent the two thousands
enchanted by Dora the Explorer this
Nickelodeon cartoon told the story of a
young Mexican American girl her pet
monkey boots and her magical talking
backpack if you aren't a native Spanish
speaker but you know some of the
language there's a good chance that
you'll have learned your first words in
it through the program but it wasn't
just Spanish that the show taught no
there was also math logic puzzles and
spelling and who can forget her nemesis
Swiper the thieving Fox can you remember
what Dora had to say to stop Swiper
stealing stuff it was Swiper no swiping
and she had to say it three times
coupled with that catchphrase and the
insanely catchy theme song it's no
wonder that Dora the Explorer which ran
for eight seasons is still shown today
and it's been acclaimed as one of
children's televisions most iconic
programs ever but what do you think will
happen to Dora Marquez when she grows up
well this is what we think she's going
to look like you can see that she's got
her bobbed hair cut and her pink top and
best of all the backpack is still with
her the question now remains where in
the world is d'Or going to end up
now she's an adult and will she still
have to tell Swiper to stop swiping
plenty loud from the loud house one of
the most popular Nickelodeon shows that
the channel has ever put out is the loud
house the story of Lincoln loud and his
ten sisters Lily Lisa
Lola Lana Lucy Lynne LuAnn Luna Laurie
and Lenny loud has been a worldwide
smash hit with so many different
characters it can be kind of hard to
pick a favorite to be honest with you
our favorite changes pretty much every
day
however if you were to ask us right now
we'd say that the loud house character
we like best is Lenny
she's the 16 year old who is the real
style queen of the loud family
she's also smart funny and caring she's
usually able to cope with the challenges
of being a teenager who is part of a big
family
having said that she's known to annoy
the rest of her family by using the word
life a lot the only thing is she
honestly doesn't use it all that much
like we know weird right but anyway
we're sure that you're wondering what
Lenny is going to end up like when she's
an adult well he or she is she's still
cool looking and you can see that she
has definitely maintained her totally
OnPoint fashion sense
wearing her shades on her head and her
trademark green dress let's hope that
she can develop the smarts to match her
big heart Calvin and Hobbes one
tradition that isn't quite as big these
days as it used to be is that of the
daily newspaper comic strip these three
or four panel cartoons were for a great
many people a highlight of their day if
the news was particularly grim it was
something that could raise a smile
through some tough times when you think
about them there are three that have
stood out there's Charles Schulz as
peanuts there's Jim Davis as Garfield
and there's Bill Watterson as Palvin and
Hobbes although it's still being run in
print today the original strip didn't
run for all that long just ten years
between 1985 and 1995 but despite that
millions of people across the world were
amused by the antics of the mischievious
Calvin and his sarcastic toy tiger
Hobbes
of course hops wasn't just a stuffed toy
as far as Calvin was concerned he was a
real living speaking being the last time
we saw the tooth they were in a sledge
with Calvin telling his friend let's go
exploring but we eat just like everyone
else who was enchanted by the comic
strip wondered what happened afterwards
here's one idea can you see Calvin has
matured into a rather stylish young man
with his red top and black
he's still got his spiky hair but Hobbs
is even better
he's a very noble looking tiger now
Masha
from Masha and the bear most of the
cartoon characters that we'll be looking
at today were created in the United
States that's not a huge surprise
America is the center of the Western
entertainment business so it makes sense
that that's where a lot of our
characters are going to have originated
from
however this next one is a bit different
it's Masha
from Masha and the bear this show is
Russian and proudly so it's based albeit
somewhat loosely on an old Russian fairy
tale but the show has become a massive
worldwide success story one of its
episodes recipe for disaster is the most
watched video on YouTube that isn't a
music video as of October 2017 it had
generated two and a half billion views
that's pretty awe-inspiring really oh
and here's another fun fact Marcia's
voice in the english-language version is
done by young American actress Elsie
Fisher if the name and the voice seemed
to be a little bit familiar to you
that's because you may well have heard
her before her other famous credit is
Agnes from the despicable Me movies but
anyway what do we think is going to
happen when Masha is a bit older here
she is as you can see she still has her
headscarf and her purple smock but we
would like to know where the bear is
hopefully he's still around bavin from
Teen Titans one of our favorite things
is when someone takes a great comic book
that we love and turns it into an
amazing cartoon there have been a lot of
examples of this over the years but one
of our favorites has got to be Teen
Titans this show was originally a series
of comics way back in the early 1980s
but more than 20 years after they first
appeared in print a smart commissioning
editor at the Cartoon Network decided to
bring them onto the small screen and
that was how the characters not only got
a brand new lease of life but also got
introduced to a whole new generation of
fans one of the Titans that we like the
most is Raven she's the half-demon half
as a riffian girl who has a dark side to
her but is always ready willing and able
to control machines with her psionic
abilities now we wondered what she'd
look like if she would have changed her
appearance no not into her demon form
that's something that never really goes
as well as it could but what she looked
like as a twenty-something Titan as you
can see she's still the Raven we all
know and love
she hasn't changed her costume dark blue
and purple are her favorite colors after
all but there is one big difference
yes that's it Raven is smiling Rick and
Morty
at the things we reckon that if you were
to ask a hundred people who were born in
the 1990s for their favorite cartoon
show the vast majority of them would say
Rick and Morty this Cartoon Network show
has become quite the go-to place for
Millennials to get both their laughs and
their catchphrases if you look on social
media the show's titular characters are
absolutely everywhere people can't get
enough of the alcoholic Scientists Rick
Sanchez and his put upon and gullible
grandson Morty Smith did you know that
the show's co-creator Justin roiland
voices both of the two main characters
oh and if you always thought that they
look a little bit like Doc Brown and
Marty McFly from the Back to the Future
films you'd be onto something
the characters were originally a parody
of doc and Marty with a lot of the
cartoon characters we'll be looking at
today we've had to make them older now
we've done that with Morty but what
we've done with Rick is that we've made
him a little bit younger so it's like
the two our brothers rather than being
grandfather and grandson you can see
that Morty seems to have got a bit of
Rick's devil-may-care swagger to him
he's even heavy ear pierced meanwhile
Rick looks really rather dashing but his
gray hair is now brown and he looks
ready to raise some hell Stewie Griffin
from Family Guy when Family Guy first
premiered on the Fox Network in 1999
people went crazy they had never seen
anything quite like it now Seth
MacFarlane's fast-paced wisecracking
saga of the Griffin family and their
lives in Quahog Rhode Island are firmly
part of popular culture the show's
characters and catchphrases are familiar
to people who have never even watched
the program now one of the most popular
and certainly one of the most
interesting we think is Stewie Griffin
he's the little baby with the upper
class British accent in the early
seasons he had some strong homicidal
tendencies and wanted to get rid of his
mother Lois
fortunately for everybody concerned this
calmed down as the show progressed more
recently he has been just as outrageous
and twice as flamboyant and he doesn't
want to kill anyone one of the many
interesting things about Stewie is that
he turned one year old in the first
series but since then he had been aged
at all so we thought about what would
happen to Stewie if
aged a lot how would he be if he were a
man in his late middle age there you are
what do you think you can see that he
evidently grew his hair only to lose
most of it again he's still kitted out
in his dungarees as a stubbly kind of
moustache and he's smoking a cigar
how lovably sleazy Moana we all enjoyed
the 2016 smash hit movie Moana Disney's
tale of a Polynesian princess who
travels the seas and saves her Island
from a blight was yet another success
from the legendary animation studio in
the title character we find a new
exciting addition to the pantheon of
Disney Princesses are you ready to see
what she looks like as an adult here you
go
as you can see she hasn't changed that
much she's a young woman rather than a
girl but she still looks as brave and
fearless as she did on the big screen
Moana was a great film that opened up
many minds young and not so young to
different worlds and cultures what was
so awesome is that many of the movies
voice cast were of either Hawaiian Maori
or Polynesian descent let's look at
Moana zeliha Carvalho she's a native
Hawaiian she was just 14 when the film
was cast two years younger than her
character is when we meet her
there's also doing Johnson the former
WWE Champion is of samoan origin and has
been known to watch the country's rugby
union team
she's even admitted that rugby is the
hardest physical challenge he's ever
competed in and that's got us all
thinking what's the toughest physical
challenge you've ever taken part in let
us know in the comments and that's all
for our 10 kids cartoon characters
reimagined as adults we hope you liked
it if you did why not check out our 5
cartoon reboots that are way better than
the original thanks for watching and
remember to subscribe
[Music]